اهلا بكم في تغطيه متواصله من العربيه
لزلزال تركيا وسوريا بعد مضي اكثر من 100
ساعه وفقدان الامل شيئا فشيئا بالوصول الى
نجين ارتفع عدد القتلى الى اكثر من
22300 شخص في تركيا وبحسب اداره الكوارث
تجاوز عدد القتلات 18 و 342 قتيلا واكثر
من 74 الف مصاب اما في سوريا في شمال
سوريا اعلنت الحكومه السوريه انها حصيله
القتلى وصلت الى اربعه الاف وسبعه وثلاثين
وهي مرشحه للوصول الى السته الاف في
الاثناء اعلن النظام مناطق حلب واللاذقيه
حماه وادلب مناطق منكوبه جراء الدمار
الواسع الذي تسبب به الزلزال
وتتواصل عمليات الانقاذ في غازي عنتاب وفي
المدن المنكوبه وتحديدا في المدن الاكثر
تضررا ان نتحدث عن عنتاب وايضا عن اليمان
ولكن سننتقل اولا الى كلمه الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان من اليمن
هذا الزلزال او هذين
الاول زرت مدينه كهرمان
[موسيقى]
هناك وشخص الحاله التي يعيشها الناس ويوم
امس كنت في غازي عنتاب واسمانيا
وايضا
المتضررين من هذه الزلازل واليوم وهنا نحن
في اليمن بعد قليل ساتوجه من هنا الى
مدينه
[موسيقى]
هنا في هذه المدينه اتمنى الشفاء لجرحانا
واعزي تعريفه
كلمه
هذا الزلزال اعرف انا لا كلمات تعبر عن
حاله عن حزننا هنا
الى
18,991 وعدد المصابين
وصل الى
75,570 شخص تقريبا
تم اجلاء المواطنين الذين كانوا يهربون
بالخروج من هذه المدن الى المدن
المجاوره
حوالي 1900 مبنى هنا في هذه المدينه
ان مقام الذين اتوفو جراء هذه
الشهاده ونحن نعتقد انهم شهداء باذنه
تعالى
اود ان اؤكد لاقارب
المتوفيين
لاننا سنساعدكم في كل شيء
وطبعا المتضررين هنا عليهم الا يقلقوا
ابدا
سنعيد اعمار هذه المدينه بكل الطرق وفي
اقصر وقتا ممكن
يشتري له رمى هنا
في هذه المناطق في كل المنطقه في العشر
مدن ونقدم المساعدات ونكرس كل امكانياتنا
وامكانيات الدوله لتقديم المساعده طبعا
مناطق زلزال المتضرره
تقع في منطقه واسعه جدا طبعا تبلغ هذه
المساحه حوالي 500
التوجه الى هذه المنطقه والتدخل في كل
منطقه ربما يصعب علينا
ولذلك انا اتخذ بعض سنعاني بعض الصعوبه في
هذا الامر وطبعا المانع الاخر هو عوامل
الجو وظروف الصعبه والظروف الشتويه الصعبه
هناك
صعوبات بسبب الطقس وبسبب دمار في بعض
الطرق وايضا بسبب ازدحام في الطرق بسبب
السيارات المتوجهه الى المدينه ومن
المدينه طبعا اتحدث عن العشر مدن
المتاثره من هذه الزلازل ولكن
امكانيات الممكنه في هذه الى هذه المنطقه
كل امكانيات الدوله تتواجد هنا الان ونقدم
كل المساعدات الممكنه وكل مؤسسات الدوله
الان تعمل من اجل
المنكوبه كما تعلمون اتخذنا قرار اعلان
حاله الطوارئ في الطوارئ في العشر مدن
ولكن علي ان اذكر هذه النقطه مع الاسف
هناك بعض الناس الذين
يهاجمون الاسواق والمحال التجاريه ويسرقون
منها السلع ويذهبون هذه السلع والبعض
يحاول سرقه هذه
المستلزمات والمواد والسلع الان الدوله
اتخذت هذه التدابير والان الخطوه ستكون
اكثر عنفا مع هؤلاء الذين يهاجمون ويسرقون
وطبعا سيتم فورا معاقبه هؤلاء باشد الطرق
ربما بعض الصعوبات وبعض النقص الذي عنينا
منه في هذه الفتره ولكن الدوله ومؤسساتها
تتواجد هنا
وتقدم كل المساعدات للمحتاجين
وزير المواصلات السيد عادل رئيس توجه فورا
الى هذه المدينه
ميمه
الوزير بعد ان انهى عمليه البحث والانقاذ
وتنسيق عمليات البحث والانقاذ جاء فورا
الى هذه المدينه
وساعد وزير المواصلات الذي يتواجد هنا
وكان منسق عمليات البحث والانقاذ وتقديم
المساعدات وطبعا تم تعيين بعض الولاد من
المدن الاخرى وبعض من المدن الاخرى
الاولويه هي انقاذ الانسان وانقاذ الارواح
استثمارات ثانيه وهذه كانت الاولويه منذ
اللحظات الاولى
لحدوث هذا الزلزال ولا احد يمكنه ان يستغل
او ان يحاسب هذا الامر
ليس لدينا
باننا استطعنا ان نركض لانقاذ كل الارواح
ولنسعى لانقاذ كل الارواح في العشر المدن
المنكوبه الى حد الان تستمر عمليات البحث
والانقاذ مع فرق الانقاذ التي جاءتنا من
الدول الاخرى وهناك عرض 94 دوله لتقديم
مساعداتهم والى حد الان تستمر الفرق
بالتوجه الى هذه المنطقه من عدد كبير من
الدول ولان الدمار كان قد
اثر على منطقه كبيره جدا وهناك
التي تتالف من 141 الف فرد
الى حد الان جمعنا اكبر عدد ممكن ربما هذا
الفريق الذي يعمل هنا هو اكبر فريق
يعمل في منطقه منكوبه حول العالم ولكن الى
حد الان هناك مناطق لم نتمكن من الوصول
الى تقديم مساعدتها اعتذر نحن نعلم ان
الوضع صعب جدا ولكن الدوله التركيه تحاول
وتسعى بكل جهودها ومع كل المنظمات ومع كل
الفرق ان تصل الى الكل هذه المناطق وتقدم
المساعدات ونحن نتفهم ونعرف جيدا ان
الجميع سعر يتفهم هذه الحاله هناك تحديات
كبيره جدا نعاني منها خلال تقديم هذه
المساعدات وابرزها شروط
ايضا اتساع الرقعه الجغرافيه هنا في مدينه
كلس
في مدينه
عمليات البحث والانقاذ والان يتم رفع
الانقاذ منها بشكل كامل ويتم العمل على
اعاده الاعمار على تقديم كل المساعدات
الممكن سنستمر بعمليه الانقاذ الى ان نخرج
اخر
مواطن عالق تحت هذه المؤكد على هذه النكته
اننا
نعيد اعمار هذه المدينه والمدن التسعه
الاخرى من خلال مشاريعنا الجديده
وناربي
نقدم ايضا المعونات الماليه
بمقدار 10 الاف ليره تركيه لكل اسره
في هذه المخيمات سندفع لهم اجور
الجنازل بشكل يعني سندفع ايجار المنازل
وسعر ايجاد المنازل
سيتوجهون الى اخرى عفوا بيوت اخرى ومنازل
اخرى في مدينه قضيه مان كما اننا سنسعى
لمساعدتهم وتقديم المعونه الماليه لهم
بدفع اجور اجار المنازل لمده عام واحد في
المدن الاخرى في هذه الفتره سنكون قد
اكملنا اعاده الاعمار في هذه المدن ونسلم
المنازل لاهاليها في كل
[موسيقى]
المتطوعين وفرق الانقاذ
ونرى كل الشباب المتطوعين الذين يقدمون كل
المساعدات الممكنه هنا ويساهمنا في عمليه
البحث والانقاذ الى حد الان تستمر
[موسيقى]
متانتناديه ونحن نرى
قوه هذا الشعب ومكانه هذا الشعب هذا الشعب
هو الشعب يتولد وشعب يثق بقوه الله يثق
بايمان انه سيستغل
كان دائما يثق بحكومته ونحن
قد وجهنا هذه الصعوبات في بعض
دراسه
مع الاسف
الى الجانب شعبنا والى جانب اخواننا
وسلمنا المنازل لاصحابها والان ايضا سنفعل
شيئا ذاته بدانا بالاستعدادات
الوزراء المعنيين وايضا وزاره
جميع الان يعمل
من اجل البدء في اقترب
وايضا بدايه الاعمال
في هذه الاثناء
موجود
الفنادق في المدن المختلفه
وسنتمكن من ارسال المواطنين الذين يرغبون
بالتوجه الى هذه الفنادق والسكن هناك
كل الطرق وايضا سندفع كل الاجور الممكنه
هناك ما انهم هم سيصادفون
المواطنين بشكل مجاني ايضا الخطوط الجويه
مجانيه اؤكد على هذه النقطه الرحلات
الجويه مجانيه
لايصال المواطنين المتضررين من الزلازل
الى المدن السليمه الاخرى لدينا مطابخ
مؤقته متحركه لدينا ايضا
المشافي
الميدانيه لدينا الكثير من
وقوات الدرك وايضا الفرق الدفاع المدني
الجميع لديه دور فعال الان في تامين هذه
المناطق والمشاركه ايضا في عمليه البحث
والانقاذ كل فرق الامن
القوات القوات المسلحه التركيه
يستخدمونها
الخاصه بالبناء وانقاذ وكل ما يلزم كل هذه
الالات والسيارات والمركبات كلهم يتواجد
هنا الان ليقدموا المساعدات
لان الناس علي ان اؤكد ان اي شخصيه سياسيه
اي مؤسسه
اخرى تنشر اكذب على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي او تحاول ان تنجر الفتنه وقعها
او حتى في الاعلام عليكم الا تصدقوهم
ارجوكم لا تصدقوهم هذا الشعب شعب الصين
هذا الشعب
الله
الى هنا بشكل كبير جدا
في ارسال هذه المواد وتوزيعها والان يتم
العمل ايضا على
توزيعها بشكل
اداره الكوارث والطوارئ الطبيعيه تلصق كل
عمليات
المساعدات
نرجو منكم ان تتواصلوا مع اداره الكوارث
والطوارئ التركيه والهلال الاحمر
المسؤولين عن توزيع هذه المساعدات وبعد
ذلك يمكنكم ارسال
المساعدات الاهم هنا تقديم المساعدات
بالتنسيق لان ارسال الشاحنات والمساعدات
قبل تنسيق او من دون تنسيق يعد بنا فعل
احد من المهم توفير الامكانيه اللوجستيه
لتوزيع هذه المساعدات هناك احتياجات
ستستمر ربما لاشهر طويله جدا لذلك نحتاج
الى فعاليه مساعدات طويله الامد ستساعد
الجميع في الفتره المقبله من الضروري ايضا
ان تكون عمليه المساعدات
تصل الى هذه المنطقه عن طريق افاد اي
اداره الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه الرجال
الاعمال والتجار والطلاب وكل
شيء
الى اداره الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه يتم
انفاق كل الليره منها ليره تركيه منها الى
اعاده اعمار هذه المدن والى تقديم
المساعدات اللازمه الى هذه
هذه الزلازل ونحتاج دعم العالم ايضا
لاعاده الاعمار في اقصد وقت ممكن بالاضافه
الى التقديم كل المساعدات الممكن
انزلنا
ان الجميع سيوله التركيه والحكومه التركيه
مواطنين وشعبها هذه
انطاليا
جانب الشعوب في الزلازل الاخرى وفي السيول
والفيضانات وحرائق الغابات في كل شيء
استطعنا الجروح في اكثر وقت ممكن
ايضا سنكون قادرين على اعاده اعمار هذه
المدن في هذا الاطار
[موسيقى]
سنقدم الدعم المالي للمتضررين من هذه
الزلازل من المدفوعات الخاصه الطارئه
[موسيقى]
الان نستعد ايضا لرفع هذه
سنقدم الدعم المالي لدفع الايجارات
المنزليه في هذه المدن والذين يرغبون
بالتوجه الى مدن
الشعبنا نتغلب على هذه المصيبه ايضا
[موسيقى]
علينا
هذه المنطقه ماليا وليذهب ويسرقوا السلع
منها
سنقضي على ذلك كما اننا سنقضي على
الشخصيات التي تستغل هذه الفرصه السياسيا
ونحاسبهم جميعا
لحدوث هذه الزلازل وقف الى الجانبنا
الكثير من المنظمات القوات المسلحه وفرق
الانقاذ واداره الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه
والمتطوعين والفرق المدنيه
ومنظمات التابعه للحكومه وايضا المنظمات
المدنيه والجميع نشكر كل من وقف الى جانب
الشعب التركي في هذه المحنه
اذا مشاهدينا كانت هذه كلمه كانت هذه
كلمات الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان من
اديمان وهو يقف على الاضرار التي خلفتها
هذه الكارثه ومن هنا قال انه سيتوجه الى
ملاطيا التي حدثت فيها هزه ارتداديه
بالمناسبه قبل 15 دقيقه وتحدث بان واكد ان
الهزات الارتداديه لا تزال مستمره اذا
الرئيس التركي حدث ايضا
اعطى احدث الارقام حول الوفيات قال ان عدد
الوفيات ارتفع الى اكثر من 18
و990 قتيلا في الزلزال وايضا
75,570 الف جريح تحدث عن اجلاء الناجين من
المدن المنكوبه الى مدن اخرى وكذلك قال
انه في اليمن هناك 1900
بالكامل طمئن سكان اليمن رئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان وتحدث عن اعاده الاعمار في اقصر
وقت ممكن وخاصه بذلك الولايات العاشره
المنكوبه ايضا تحدث عن صعوبه
الاوضاع والاحوال الجويه التي تعطل عمليات
الانقاذ لكن قال انه تم وضع جميع
الامكانيات للدوله وتم تقديم كل المساعدات
المطلوبه للعشر مدن من قبل الحكومه تحدث
عن عمليات ايضا النهب وشدد على مواجهتها
باشد الوسائل في المدن المنكوبه كان يتحدث
الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان عن هذه العمليات
والتي جاءت بالاساس في تقارير عده تحدث
ايضا عن صعوبات ونقص المتطلبات في هذه
الفتره واكد حرصه على انقاذ جميع الارواح
في اربعين
وتقديم 94 دوله
للمساعده في تركيا ايضا شدد الرئيس رجب
طيب اردوغان على الخطوط الجويه التي
التركيه التي قدمت الرحلات ابي المجان
لاجلاء المتضررين الى مدن اخرى اذا وننتقل
ايضا الى ادمان عبر الهاتف سينضم الينا
محمود الشكر موفد العربيه من هناك وايضا
نتابع على هذه الشاشه الصور المباشره
تاتينا من اسكندرون حول انقاذ شخص من تحت
الانقاض وهي مشاهد في الحقيقه تبعث على
الامل خاصه بعد خمسه ايام من وقوع هذا
الزلزال في جنوب تركيا وشمال سوريا والذي
تضررت فيه عشر ولايات تركيه يعني الامل
كانت تتلاشى شيئا فشيئا مع دخول ايضا هذه
الموجه البارده درجات حراره ما دون الصفر
ليلا وهي تصعب عمليات الانقاذ وبالطبع
الاجلاء
للمتضررين من هذه المدن اضافه الى الطرق
المتضرره في جميع هذه الولايات اذا محمود
شكر انتقل اليك بعد هذه الكلمه للرئيس رجب
طيب اردوغان تحدث عن تقديم جميع المساعدات
الممكنه لاديمان ولكن لو تطلعنا على
الاوضاع لديك عمليات الانقاذ الى اين وصلت
نعلم حتى الان انها انتهت من اورفا وايضا
من كلس ولكن الدمار فيها كبير جدا
في بدايه هذه الرساله او اعلق على كلمه
رئيس الجمهوريه تركيا بالمقاطعه على الارض
من خلال البنود التي قام بها في هذا
الخطاب بدايه كان هنالك عندنا معلومات منذ
ايام عديده الى ان الطيران التركي فعلا ما
ان وقع الزلزال حتى فتح المطار في منطقه
بعيده عن هذه المدينه حوالي 125 كيلو متر
وكان الجو السائد هنا في داخل المدينه
وبين العائلات انه من يريد ان ينتقل منها
الى المطار ثم بعد ذلك ياخذ الطيران
باتجاه اي مدينه يريد هما يستطيع ان يفعل
وهذا ايضا ما رفضناه مقلب الثاني بقضيه
المساعدات وتحديد هذه المساعدات بعده
تشعبات منها مساعدات للماوى منها مساعدات
للتعاون هنا مساعدات للمياه ومن المساعدات
الاخذ ومنها مساعدات الطبيه في هذه البنود
الخمسه استطيع القول للغرابه
اذا التعبير في هذا التفصيل الى انه عشرات
المئات من الافضل من المواد الغذائيه هي
اصبحت مكدسه في هذه المدينه انت تستطيعين
مواطنه او كزائره او ايضا تركيا او كنازح
سوري ان يمشي في الطريق وان ياخذ من على
جوانب الطريق المياه المقدسه الخبز المقدس
المواد الغذائيه ايضا فضلا عن المطابخ
التي هي وزعت كما اشرنا في الرسائل
السابقه في عده مناطق معينه التي تقدم
المياه الساخنه والمياه العدس والشوربه
والطعام والشاي كل هذه الامور ويبدو ايضا
لاننا وصلنا في اليوم الثاني هذا من الى
المدينه هذا المساعدات الدوليه او العربيه
او الاقليميه التي تواصل تباعا الى هذه
المدينه يبدو الى ان
الهبه او الهمه التركيه ما بين الشعب
التركي مع بعضه البعض كانت مع ساعات
الاولى لهذا الزلزال نحن نرى هنا في نعم
نرى هناك التي تنقل المتطوعين والمتطوعات
والذين نستطيع ان نميزهم من خلال اللباس
جنين موحد لهم اذا سالت عن هذا فقال هذه
من المحافظه الفلانيه للمحافظه الفلانيه
هؤلاء من الجمعيه الفلانيه باعداد كبيره
لتصفح الذي قال فيه رئيس الجمهوريه ان
فريقها كبير جدا وانا الذي اراه او الذي
اتعجب منه هو عمليه التحكم والسيطره
بتوزيع هذه الفرق المتطوعه التي تصل
بالالاف تباعا وراء بعضها البعض وهي موزعه
على
ننسى لا ننسى يعني هناك اكثر من سته الاف
فريق دولي من 56 دوله وايضا تحدث عن اكثر
من 90 دوله عرضت المساعده في الانقاذ في
هذه الفتره وايضا تحدث رئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان على ضروره التنسيق لارسال
المساعدات وشدد عليها من ناحيه الامكانيه
اللوجستيه ولوضع اليه مساعدات طويله الامد
اذا سنبقى معك في سياق هذه التغطيه ونعود
اليك لاحقا شكرا لك محمود شكر موفد
العربيه من اليمن
[موسيقى]
ومع عقول وقوع الزلزال المدمر في تركيا
وسوريا يسعى رجال الانقاذ للاستعانه بكل
ما يمكن من الحيوانات وادوات للوصول الى
لجنه تحت الانقاض لاسيما ان عمليه البحث
خلال هذه الكوارث من اصعب عمليات الانقاذ
واكثرها تعقيدا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الصمت هنا مختلف ليس كاي صمت حتى انه عرف
بصمت الموت فعلى طريق النجاه ينادي
المنقذون بصوت واحد ثم يصمتون جميعا
وسيله استخدمها المنقذون للعثور على
ناجيين في سوريا وعلى قله الامكانيات ولو
كان الامل ضعيفا بوجود انفاس تحت هذه
الانقاض يحاول عمال البحث بطرق بدائيه
وتقليديه
في ظل تعقيد البحث وصعوبه الوصول وسماع
الناجين تحت اقوام الركام تطورت ادوات
البحث لنجده العالقيين فاعتمد الخبراء على
تقنيات تكنولوجيه تطورت عبر الزمن ومن
ابرزها الفئران والصراصير المزوده
بكاميرات صغيره القادره على الدخول الى
امكنه لا يمكن رؤيتها او حتى سماع اصوات
تطلب استغاثه الافعى الروبوت على شكل
ثعبان ليستطيع صعود درجات عاليه والتنقل
عبر المساحات الضيقه تقنيه حديثه يسعى
الباحثون لاستخدامها الطائرات المسيره
بامكانها فصل الاحياء عن الاموات عن طريق
الكشف عن حركه بسيطه للضحايا وحده فايندر
تاتي بحجم حقيبه اليد ترسل موجات دقيقه
منخفضه الطاقه ويمكن ان تكشف الموجات عن
خفيه مثل النبض الخفيف للجلد الذي يكشف عن
دقات القلب
مشعلا مصباحه ينادي مسابقا الزمن اعلى
صوته ينجح في انقاذ عالق من قبضه تلك
الانقاض بشتى الطرق وباي طريقه كانت يحاول
ولا يزال
عصام عبد السلام العربيه
فرق الطوارئ في سوريا ان العديد من
المنازل في مدينه حلب التي ت ضرب الاكثر
ايلاما من الزلزال تضررت بشكل كبير او
انهارت تماما وبحسب الفرق لا يزال الكثير
من السكان عالقنا تحت الانقاض انقاض
البنايات في حلب التي يقيم فيها ملايين
اللاجئين الذين تشردوا بعدما افقدتهم
الحرب الاهليه منازلهم
ولا نزال في مدينه حلب فقد شاب سوري
عائلته في غضون ثوان معدوده على حد وصفه
متاثرين بتراكم الحطام حطام المباني
المنهاره جراء الزلزال المدمر
[موسيقى]
عيلتي اهلي كل الروحي
اهلي كلهم راحوا ابوي وامي
واخوي واختي وابن اختي ما عم بصدق ما بصدق
يا جماعه ما بصدق
[موسيقى]
انا بقطع القمه الاوروبيه عن تضامنها مع
الشعبين التركي والسوري واكد رئيس القمه
في مؤتمر صحفي على هامش اجتماعات القمه
الاوروبيه في بروكسل استمرار تعبئه على
الصعيد الاوروبي من اجل توفير اللازم
للمنكوبين ضحايا الزلزال في البلدين
القمه الاوروبيه ضحايا زلزال وتعلن عن عزم
الاتحاد والدول الاعضاء التحرك من اجل دعم
المنكوبين ومساعده الذين بقوا على قيد
الحياه وتقديم المساعدات في عمليه البحث
والانقاذ والنجده كما وقع جميع قاده دول
الاتحاد كتابه تعزيه وتضامن الى الرئيس
اردوغان وتعلن القمه عن مواصله التعبئه من
اجل تخفيف معاناه السكان ضحايا الماساه
الجاريه القمه الاوروبيه ترحب بمبادره
المفوضيه الاوروبيه والسويد تنظيم مؤتمر
للمانحين في غضون شهر مارس المقبل من اجل
دعم المناطق المنكوبه في تركيا وسوريا
وتوفير الدعم اللازم
ايضا ما قال المكلف بالتواصل باللغه
العربيه في الخارجيه الفرنسيه ان الرئيس
ايمانويل ماكرون طلب تحريك المساعدات
لسوريا وتركيا على المستويين الفرنسي
والاوروبي مشيرا الى ان باريس ترسل الى
تركيا مستشفى الميدانيا
فورا منذ البدايه طلب رئيس الجمهوريه
تحريك
مساعده الفرنسيه
[موسيقى]
كجواب لطلبه قدمتها تركيا
فتعتر رعايه
حركه مركز الازمات والمسانده التابعه
لوزاره الخارجيه التنسيق على السعيده
الاوروبي الداخلي مع وزاره الاخرى المعنيه
او وزاره الداخليه من بيدها
لتقديم
مساعده دعم ندرس حاليا
وسائل يعني تقديم هذا
المستشفى الميداني
وكما تفضلت هو قادر على معالجه مئات
الجرحى يوميا
هذا هو اعلنت نائبه المبعوث الاممي الخاص
لسوريا نجاه رشدي عن حاجه المناطق مناطق
شمال غرب البلاد لمزيد من الدعم العاجل
لتلبيه الاحتياجات المتزايده بعد الزلزال
الذي وقع الاثنين الماضي
في الاثناء اعلنا برنامج الاغذيه العالميه
ان مخزونه ينفدع في شمال غرب سوريا داعيا
الى فتح المزيد من المعابر الحدوديه من
تركيا الى الشمال السوري حيث يعتمد 90% من
السكان على المساعدات الانسانيه وكذا
المدير الاقليمي لبرنامج الاغذيه العالمي
في الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا كورن
فلايشر ان هناك حاجه الى تجديد المخزون
ومن جهته ايضا افاد مراسل العربيه بوصول
قافله مساعده امميه مكونه من اربعه عشره
شاحنه الى معبر باب الهوى على الحدود بين
تركيا وسوريا متجهه للشمال الغربي وهي
اولى القوافل التي اتدخل الى سوريا بعد
خمسه ايام من حدوث الزلزال
ومشاهدينا من هناك ومن معبر باب الهوى
ينضم الينا الصحفي محمد الاشقر محمد اهلا
بك كنا معك في وقت سابق وذكرت ان هناك
شاحنه قد دخلت الى الشمال السوري كم بلغ
عدد الشاحنات حتى الان
يعني في الحقيقه دخلت ظهر
نعم
نحمل
مساعد
هناك مشكله في الصوت
اذا سنعود الى الصحفي محمد الاشقر من معبر
باب الهوى حينما
تتحسن هذه المشكله او تتصلح اذا بعد مرور
نحو
103 ساعات من محاصرته بالانقاض تحت الارض
رجل يبلغ من العمر 66 عاما ينجو من الموت
بعد العثور عليه من قبل قوات الانقاذ في
تركيا
حسنا
[موسيقى]
جمعه الحمله الشعبيه السعوديه لاغاثه
المتضررين بالزلزال في سوريا وتركيا جماعه
تبرعات باكثر من 200 مليون ريال وانطلقت
الحمله قبل ايام عبر منصه ساهم بعد توجيه
العاهل السعوديه الملك سلمان بن عبد
العزيز ووليد العهد الامير محمد بن سلمان
وكان مركز الملك سلمان للاغاثه والاعمال
الانسانيه اكد ان المساعدات السعوديه ستصل
للمحتاجين حيثما كانوا
وسنعود الان الى الصحفي محمد الاشقر من
باب معبر باب الهوى اذا محمد كنت اسالك عن
الشاحنات التي يعني هي جزء من القافله
الدوليه التي ستدخل من معبر باب الهواء
الى الشمال السوري كم بلغ عدد الشاحنات
التي دخلت بالفعل الى شمال سوريا
نعم اليوم ظهر اليوم دخلت قافله مساعدات
امميه مؤلفه من 14 شاحنه دخلت الى شمال
غرب سوريا عبر بوابه باب الهوى الحدوديه
مع تركيا تحمل هذه الشاحنات مساعدات يطلق
عليها مساعدات الكوارث الطوارئ وهي مؤلفه
من سلل اغاثيه من صله الغذائيه وسلل نظافه
بالاضافه للاغطيه
وبعض الاسفنجات طبعا هذه ال ال14 قافله
دخلت ظهر اليوم ايضا دخلت خمسه شاحنات
بشكل منفصل
تركيا وصلت ايضا
لو تعيد علينا هذه المعلومه خمس شاحنات
بشكل منفصل من اين
نعم نعم بشكل منفصل دخلت عبر معبر باب
الهوان عن طريق منظمه اياها التركيه وكنا
قد استقبلنا احد الاطباء المصريين
العاملين في منظمه في مداخله سابقه وتحدث
عن هذه القافله التي دخلت ايضا الى شمال
غرب سوريا طبعا يوم امس ايضا دخلت احتوت
هذه هذه الشاحنات اللي احتوت على على خيام
من منظمه اياها لان
القافله الامميه لم تحتوي على خيام
نعم يعني حتى هذه اللحظه شمال غرب سوريا
لا يزال بحاجه خيام نتيجه عدد السكان
الهائل الذي الى حد هذه اللحظه يفترش
الطرقات ومراكز الايواء المؤقته والملاعب
والحدائق طبعا بحسب حسب ما وصلنا له من
المنظمات الانسانيه العامله هنا في الشمال
السوري قالوا ان الشركائهم المنظمات
الدوليه قد وعدوهم بتسيير حافلات مع
الساعات القادمه او ربما الايام القادمه
قد تدخل الى شمال غرب سوريا وهذا ما اكده
ايضا المتحدث الرسمي باسم اداره معبر باب
الهوى ومسؤول التنسيق الاعلامي السيد مازن
علوش عندما قال ان الجانب التركي
وعدهم بان هناك قوافل ستدخل تباعا عن طريق
بوابه باب عن طريق معبر باب الهواء
الحدودي مع تركيا ست
محمد وكان ايضا هناك كان هناك ايضا الدوله
فاتحه معبر اخر ايضا من هاتاي الى
اللاذقيه لكن هذه المساعدات متاخره
بالاساس نحن نتحدث مثلا عن جنديرس في ريف
حلب الاكثر تضررا نتحدث عن 2900 عائله في
العراء تم فقط توفير الخيام لخم
منها يعني عدم احتواء هذه الشحنات على
خيام الى اي مدى قد يساعد السوريين في
شمال سوريا
نعم يعني في الحقيقه الوضع كارثي هنا في
في شمال غرب سوريا الاف العوائل هم بحاجه
خيام الان كنا في السابق نناشد باخراج
الاهالي من الخيام نتيجه المعاناه التي
يعانونها والان اصبحت هذه الخيمه حلما
للكثير من السوريين هنا في شمال غرب سوريا
الى حتى اليوم وهو اليوم الخامس عن بدء
هذه الكارثه التي ضربت المنطقه اثناء
تجولنا في الاماكن المتضرره ولقائنا مع
الاهالي خصوصا يوم امس في مدينه جنديرس
احدى اكبر المدن التي تعرضت للكارثه كثير
من الاهالي لا يزال يفترش الطرقات تحت
اشجار الزيتون يلجاون
رغم التطوعيه والمنظمات الانسانيه
والاهالي قاموا بانشاء مراكز ايواء مؤقته
ولكن يبدو ان مراكز الايواء هذه لم تتسع
لهذا العدد الهائل من النازحين من
المحتاجين طبعا جميع السوريين هنا في
الداخل
ما خففت نوعا ما وبشكل نسبي بسيط من هذه
الكارثه طبعا
اليوم عن طريق نعم
محمد
كنت اتحدث على ان ما دخل الى سوريا
لا يكفي الا جزء بسيط من حجم المحتاجين
هنا نحن
نعم نعم محمد الصوت لا يزال يتقطع اذا كنت
تتحدث ان هذه المساعدات لا تكفي كنا نتحدث
عن جنديرس ولكن ايضا هذه في ريف حلب هناك
ايضا في ريف ادلب جارمه حارم وسلقين ايضا
هي من الاكثر تضررا بحاجه ماسه لجميع
وسائل المساعده ونذكر ايضا انه تم اعلان
حماه اللاذقيه ادلب وحلب مناطق منكوبه
اليوم في سوريا اشكرك جزيل الشكر كنت معنا
من معبر باب الهواء الصحفي محمد الاشقر
يا طيب طيب حاول
[موسيقى]
يا رب
يلا يلا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اذن مشاهدينا سنعود ونذكر بكلمه الرئيس
التركي قبل قليل في سياق هذه التغطيه اعلن
عن اجلاء اكثر من خمسه وسبعين الف شخص من
المناطق المنكوبه بالزلزال والذي ضرب
البلاد والى ولايات اخرى تم اجلائهم ومنهم
حوالي
467 اشخاص عن طريق البر والسكك الحديديه
واكثر من 24 الفا عن طريق الجو وايضا بحسب
هيئه اداره الكوارث التركيه سيتم وضع
الاشخاص الذين تم اجلائهم في مناطق
الاقامه التي حددتها مكاتب الولايه واداره
الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه
[موسيقى]
يا الله
تعال تعال غطيها تعال غطيها تعال
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
توقعت وكاله للتصنيف الائتمانيه ان تتجاوز
الخسائر الاقتصاديه جراء الزلزال مليارات
دولار وقد تصل الى اربعه مليارات دولار او
حتى اكثر تعرضت الاف البنايات بما في ذلك
منازل ومستشفيات فضلا عن طرق وخطوط انابيب
وبنيه تحتيه اخرى
لاضرار جسيمه اذا وللمزيد ينضم الينا من
اسطنبول نعم ليس ليس جاهزا اذا سنعود اليه
في سياق هذه التغطيه مشاهدينا
[موسيقى]
اذا والان من اسطنبول ينضم الينا الكاتب
الصحفي فراس رضوان اوغلو اهلا بك اذا خامس
يوم على وقوع هذا الزلزال في تركيا وفي
العشر مناطق المنكوبه هناك ما انتهت فيه
عمليات الانقاذ كاشل اورفا وكلس ولكن ايضا
هناك ما اقترب من الانتهاء في العمليات
كديار بكر اضنه وعثمانيه ولكن تبقى هذه
المناطق بحاجه ماسه الى مساعدات الى اعاده
اعمار في مرحله لاحقه وهناك من هم في
العراء يحاولون العوده الى منازلهم التي
تضررت ولم تتهدم كل هذه الاجراءات هل تسير
الخطوات على الطريق الصحيح
يعني ممكن ان نقول نعم تسير على الخطوات
الصحيح وبسرعه كبيره لكن
هل هذه الخطوات يعني هي التكسي حتى الان
انا اظن حتى الان ما زال هناك بعض العاجز
في بعض الامور يعني سواء الايواء
والاحتواء نحن نتكلم عن عشر ولايات بمدنها
وقراها لذلك يعني كل الجهود تبذل لا يوجد
احد تقريبا في كافه المدن التركيه
بمعنى ان الموظفوا البلديه وعمال الطرق
والعمال ما نجموا من يستطيع ان يكون
مساهما في اعمال اللوجستيك للمنقذين
وغيرهم كلهم ارسلوا الى تلك المحافظات ومع
ذلك
ما زال هناك نقص حتى الان المسؤولون
الاتراك يقولون يعني
خيمه ونحن نتكلم عن مدينه واحده
من اكثر الدول المناطق تضررا في هذا
الزلزال وهناك عشرات الالاف مئات الالاف
في العراق 25 الف خيمه من تكفي
نعم ولذلك
يعني هناك بعض السفراء الذين من قبل تركيا
للكتب او كتابه عفوا مطالبهم المحتاجات
الاوليه طبعا هناك كثير من
المعونات القادمه من المدن الاخرى التركيه
لكن
طرقات المقدمه
عدم سهوله الوصول الى كثير من المناطق هذه
ايضا مشكله اخرى يعني في حد ذاتها ربما
ايضا
المس القاذبه من الخارج تخزن في
مناطقها اللوجستيه التي وضعت من بينهم
مدينه اضنه وبعدها يتم توزيعها على
الولايات العشره يعني شرقا او غربا في هذا
الاتجاه لكن نحن نتكلم على اكثر من نقل
خمسه عشر مليون ساكن في في تلك المنطقه
بشكل عام نتكلم عن المدن بعضها خرج عن
نطاق
السكنطاكيا عثمانيه
نحن نتكلم ايضا وهناك ايضا عمليات تقييم
للمنازل التي اتضررت ولم تنهار من قبل
الفرق هندسيه هل تسير هذه العمليه بشكل
سريع ام ان هناك تاخير بحكم جميع المعوقات
اللوجستيه
نعم نعم لا تسير بشكل سريع ليس فقط
العدد الكبير يعني الان هم يحصون تقريبا
عشر مدن وعشر ولايات عفوا بمدنها وقررها
وريفها لذلك العدد كبير جدا
تحتاج اظن بعض الوقت لان هذا شخص جنسي
الهندسي يعني يحتاج كثير من الوقت لذلك
على الاقل الان ليس قبل شهر انا اظن لن
تنتهي
الاجراءات الهندسيه في نصف الولايات لذلك
هذا الامر طويل لانه كما قال وزير البيئه
لا يمكن العوده الى المنازل دون فحصها
التي هي في حالتها الجيده كما بالك التي
مهدمه او التي جزء معظم منها والتي حجم
فيها بعض الاثار فهو يقول هل نخدمها من
جديد هذا كله يحتاج الى ت في كثير من
المساحات الواسعه انا اظن ان الموضوع كبير
جدا لكن
بالمساعدات التي تاتي الى تركيا ممكن ممكن
طبعا بعد المرحله الثانيه بعد الوصول
الوصول الى المرحله الثانيه من
بعد رفع الانقاض والانقاذ نعم اشكرك جزيل
الشكر كنت معنا من اسطنبول الكاتب الصحفي
فراس رضوان اوغلو
رغم تضاؤلي حضوري اخراج ناجينا من تحت
الانقاض بمرور خمسه ايام على الزلازل
المدمره لما يفقد الشاب السوري سامر
المتطوع في فرق الانقاذ الامل في العثور
على صديقه المفقود تحت انقاذ بلده جنديرس
الشماليه سوريا ما حدا بيعرف فينا شيء
خالص خالص هنا بجنديرس شمالي سوريا حيث
النصيب الاكبر من الكارثه المتطوعون من
اهالي البلده كان وحدهم من جابها هولا
الزلزال اليوميين قبل انضمام فرق الانقاذ
قليله العدد شحيحه المعدات
بايدينا بحثنا بايدينا كريكات
بالعصي بالبواري ايش نلاقي قدامنا نعزل
طالعنا عايشين طلعنا ميتين
ضلينا لثاني يوم لحتى هون
اجا الدفاع المدني اجوا اجوا العالم
تساعدنا في جنديرس قصه البحث عن الناجين
تاخذ معنى اخر
سامر الذي انقذ العشرات منذ اربعه ايام
انهكه التعب لكن انامله لم تتوقف عن البحث
فشخص عزيز عليه تحت هذا الركام رفيق دربه
وابن حارته المدمره ما يزال في عداد
المفقودين اول بنايه وصل عليها
البنايه اللي ساكن فيها رفيقي رفيقي اسمه
علي اول ما وصلت
وارجع فقط لا غير
ضلينا نبحث لحد الان
[تصفيق]
متطوعوه جنديرس لا يحتاجون الى قوائم
المفقودين فهم يعرفون من قضى نحبه ومن
ينتظر وهذا الجهد المتواصل بالنسبه اليهم
هو الواجب اتجاه الاهل والوفاء قبل
التضامن علمنا اعز رفقاتي ابو قلب الطيب
الحنون
يعني ما فينا نقول شيء غير حسبنا الله
ونعم الوكيل
عبد القادر خربوش العربيه
وسنواصل معكم مشاهدينا تغطيتنا للزلازل
ولكن سنتوقف امام بعض الاخبار الخاصه
بالملفات الاخرى فقد رفض مندوب روسيا
الدائم لدى الامم المتحده
التي طرحتها في مبادره السلام ووصفها بغير
المقبوله واضاف المندوب الروسي ان كل
المبادرات الاوكرانيه سواء كانت في صيغه
السلام او قمه السلام هي قذائف فارغه
واضحه تهدف فقط الى التاثير الدعائي وفق
تعبيره معتبرا انه من الواضح ان الشروط
المنصوص عليها فيها غير مقبوله
اكد الجيش الاوكراني في بيانه اليوم ان
القوات الروسيه كثفت من هجماتها الصاروخيه
على مناطق واسعه شرقيه اوكرانيا تمهيدا
لهجوم بري واسع في الذكرى الاولى لاندلاع
الحرب واضاف بيان الجيش الاوكراني ان
مدينه تعرضت لقصف مكثف يوم امس فيما اكد
عمده
ان المدينه تعرضت للقصف سبعه عشره مره
خلال ساعه واحده في محاوله روسيه لاخماد
الدفاعات الاوكرانيه قبل تنفيذ هجوم شامل
على شرق اوكرانيا
وزيره الخارجيه الفرنسيه كاترين كولونا
نظيرها الامريكي
اقوى على التهديد الذي يشكله برنامج
الصواريخ البالستيه الايراني الوزيران
طلبات طهران بضروره التعاون الكامل مع
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه والوفاء
بالتزاماتها النوويه
قال الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ان المنطقه
الصيني الذي دخل المجال الجوي لبلاده لم
يشكل انتهاكا خطيرا للامن القومي للولايات
المتحده ولكنه يعتبر انتهاكا للقوانين
الدوليه كما اشار الرئيس الامريكي ان جيش
بلاده اتخذ قرارا حكيما عندما قرر اسقاط
المنطاد قباله سواحلي